speaking of old men Tom Brady Patriots
quarterback sorry oh yeah 43 years old
in August and he's you know people ask
me Chris is Tom Brady gonna become a
free agent and my response is he already
isn't free agent like what are you
talking about free agency doesn't start
until March right but what goes on now
is the teams that are interested in
players who are due to officially become
free agents they make known their
interest they make known what they're
willing to pay and that's why it's no
surprise that my crease of espn.com
reported on Sunday that there's been no
movement between the Patriots and Tom
Braden on a new contract there's there's
no reason for there to be any movement
because right now even though no one
will admit to it because it's tampering
but everybody does it Brady and his
agent Don yay are finding out what all
is out there behind door number two and
you don't go back to door number one
until you know what's out there behind
door number two and there may be
multiple teams lurking behind door
number two but for now there's nothing
to talk to the Patriots about because
Tom Brady and Don year trying to find
out what other teams are interested in
how much they're willing to pay and what
other terms may be important to Brady
and then he can go back and and try to
negotiate with the Patriots before he
officially becomes a free agent so I'm
not surprised by any of this this is
exactly the way it's gonna play out
right and and we'll see how it plays out
really after the Scouting Combine
whether or not he can work out a deal to
stay in New England well I think the
thing that I think up first off is this
gonna be the only team that jumps into
the Tom Brady conversation is this
strictly gonna it's gonna be the Oakland
Raiders and just the New England
Patriots and BAM that's it I mean that's
all that's needed I understand it from
the Raiders point of view right Mike I
mean geez Wow okay yeah you're moving to
a new stadium in Las Vegas and you want
to have Tom Brady be the starting
quarterback for that team when you open
up this new stadium and kind of
reinvigorate a fan base try to steal
fans from other cities maybe even
dominate some of the LA market that's
kind of still up for grabs in some areas
I know the Rams got a stranglehold on it
but you know there's just there's so
much there to like if you're the Oakland
Raiders and what time are the Las Vegas
Raiders excuse me I got it used to that
with Tom Brady
coming there I understand that you know
but but is it real I guess that's where
I want to go and I just know I haven't
heard anything - no it's real yet you
know just from anybody that I know
around the NFL and it's still early and
not hopefully I'll maybe get more
answers as the week goes on or is this
just totally you know hey one team kind
of flirting with a player and they're
okay with it and they're both kind of
using each other to drum up interest I
don't know I don't know what are your
thoughts well and we both are kind of
out of sync it's gonna take us a little
while to get back on the same page I was
I would and it's my fault I misread the
outline I was starting from the
perspective of no movement between the
Patriots and Brady that's my fault you
you fast forwarded to the Raiders being
interested and that's what I noticed on
Saturday morning it was funny because I
saw the tweet from Larry Fitzgerald
senior who's been a member of the media
for a long time his son obviously Larry
Fitzgerald the future Hall of Fame first
ballot hall-of-famer of the Arizona
Cardinals and it was one of those things
where I thought it's like you know Larry
Fitzgerald senior never really breaks
any news but the fact that he never
breaks any news and he's going out on a
limb with this right and when you
consider who he knows and when you
consider who his son knows it doesn't
take much to get him to the point where
he's hearing something and he believes
it's credible Raiders prepared to offer
Tom Brady 60 million over two years and
that's not an outlandish amount of money
in today's NFL especially with dak
Prescott and Patrick mahomes ready to
push the bar well above 35 million a
year potentially look III agree with you
I don't know who else is gonna be out
there Chris but one of the one of the
hot takes you missed last week was
Michael Irvin stirring things up
suggesting right Cowboys are in play for
Tom Brady which creates all sorts of
potential ramifications if the Cowboys
get exasperated with dak Prescott and
decide to go all in for one year with
Tom Brady but this is what's gonna
happen it's really gonna come to a
crescendo next week in Indianapolis
because that's when all the agents are
there all the players are there and they
get together they meet about pre agents
who's interested generally how much
they're willing to pay that all gets
resolved next week in Indianapolis it's
blatantly illegal under NFL rules it's
not illegal under another
but it's tampering but the NFL doesn't
care about it everybody does it and
that's when when Donnie leaves
Indianapolis he'll know who's in play is
it just the Raiders is it no one is it
the Raiders the Cowboys the Chargers is
it the Dolphins is it the Titans he'll
know and he'll know what they're willing
to pay and he'll know other basic terms
and that's when Tom Brady can go back
and decide whether or not he stays with
the Patriots works out a deal with the
Patriots knows what's reasonable in
light of what his market would be and if
he doesn't stay with the Patriots I mean
we get into March 5 March 7 March 10 and
there's no deal with the Patriots that
means he's leaving well yeah I don't
know if it definitely means he's you
know leaving to me I hear you it gets
dangerous stories that time that time
period you start to get down to the last
week 10 days a free agency before it
starts and there's no deal done yeah
people start to get pissed off for lack
of a better phrase there where then yes
it does become personal and Brady
probably won't like that but I mean
first off we're not shocked by this
right with New England and their
approach right now Bill Belichick as
smart as he is mr. Kraft we've heard mr.
Kraft say hey I want him to go out there
and experience free agency I mean from
everything I wouldn't think and no and
just knowing people in New England and
everything like that they're gonna
they're they're fine with Brady go out
there find some teams you know get a
market number let's see what it is okay
and then they're gonna go okay do we
want to match that market number or how
close do we have to get to match that
market number to make Tom feel happy and
is that what is that is it is it five
eight million dollars I don't know you
know to me that fur like Tom Brady to
leave the New England Patriots and go to
the Las Vegas Raiders he better get
something substantially more is he
really gonna go there and learn a new
offense and learn John Gordon's lingo
and do all that and deal with Jon Gruden
and all the newness of that situation
for what an extra three or four million
dollars a year I have a hard time
believing that I don't know about you
but you know I don't know what do you
think what's that number
if Oakland over to the 30 does does New
England offer him 25 bring them back to
New England you think
let me ask you this yeah you're assuming
that he's gonna be the square peg that
gets jammed into the round hole what if
the round hole becomes square for him
right I think that part of this is gonna
be how much do you want to pay Tom Brady
and what are you gonna do to assimilate
Tom Brady into your team and yeah and
you talked a couple of weeks ago about
how smitten Jon Gruden was with John
Brady did he he's cool when he's walking
on to and off the field showed us a tape
of him walking off the sidelines and
rewound like four or five times like we
were like watching his tushie go back
and forth like he literally was like
look at this guy isn't he he just walks
freaking you know I said some other
words he walks freaking cool and all
that and he really wound it and then we
watched it again and then he rewound it
and we watched it again so yes there's
heard to me last week I was thinking
back on what you said it's like when
when George has the crush on Tony the
memo is Jerry called him and lanes
boyfriend and is like falling around
everywhere and wants to go rock climbing
and is gonna take sandwiches like how
much is Jon Gruden willing to do to get
Tom Brady to go rock climbing with him
and making the sandwiches is the
equivalent to changing the offense to
suit Tom Brady right what all are you
willing to do yes how much are you
willing to change who you are and what
you are to have a season or two with Tom
Brady and that's part of the pitch right
yeah that's part of what that whether
it's Gruden or any other coach that's
trying to pry them away so I don't think
it's just the money and and I guess the
thing is Chris the you know if it's if
it's you're coming to LA or Las Vegas
excuse me and you have to adapt to us
then it's gonna take more money I would
take it yes that's what I'm saying if
it's we're gonna adapt to you then the
gap will be smaller potentially because
the more that that Brady is comfortable
yes with the new arrangement then the
more likely he is to make the jump I
think I I do think so as well to me
though that's just a risky proposition
by the Oakland Raiders right a young
football team Jon Gruden is just
implemented is his system really in
last two years and even he's tweaked the
language to that system to make it
easier for the young team in the free
agency and now what are you gonna do
disrupt that whole formula for a guy
like Tom Brady and just come in and go
okay hey we used to call this bingo but
now we're calling it you know some other
we're calling it dagger or something
like that I'm just giving us some words
there that are similar in the NFL world
you know and all are we gonna change all
of that for the one guy and maybe set
back a second-year player you know a
little bit of time here because he's
having to learn a new offense as well
that is risky also like I don't know I'm
just gonna throw this out there like I
don't do you think any of this is BS
maybe do a degree I mean do you I mean I
don't know is this just like hey al I
met you at the UFC every night al but
you know Mark Davis I met you at the UFC
event and you know hey we're New England
maybe I don't know the Raiders maybe
they driving up the market price old the
Patriots don't get away with sign and
Tom Brady back for a low number I don't
know I wouldn't put yeah that could be
part of it I mean yeah the Patriots can
name their price if there isn't some
other right outfit exactly that that is
that is feigning interest and then you
get into higher levels of chicanery
where you know you've got agent
relationships and the agent asked
somebody for a favor right and can you
help me out here I'm you know I'm not
you know can you mind if I float this
two years 30 million out there ya know
bright deal let's that doesn't mean aids
to me I did you did me a favor last year
or whatever
exactly and that's how the business
works the relationships are critical and
sometimes you trade favors and sometimes
you have some BS like that that gets
floated but but he's Tom Brady yeah and
you know how john bruton feels about tom
brady right right yeah and the idea that
this gets him out of the derrick karr
conundrum we know that Derek Carr isn't
good enough in Jon Gruden XY's that's a
given now sorry Derek you you can block
us on Twitter but you can't block us on
TV you can change the channel just for
Mike you don't the block me this test
you just like half the screen but but
but yeah I think it's obvious that John
Burton's not thrilled with Derek Carr
he's looking for an upgrade whether it's
Tom Brady or somebody else I think
they're gonna try to find an upgrade
this year but he is Tom Brady period and
I
I think that there is going to be
interest because it's just not football
remember that two folks you want to fill
the stadium with fans you want to sell
jerseys can you imagine a Tom Brady
Raiders Jersey Chris oh you imagine how
many of those I may buy with that one I
probably would too I'm with you I would
- that would look damn cool now Kenny
Stabler might have an issue with that
we'd have to talk to his family right is
because 12 is 12 retired by the Raiders
I'm not they don't retired retired
retired jerseys oh but that would be
cool to break out the 12 again and yes I
get all of that I really do I mean yes
Tom Brady it's it's it's an iconic
American sports icon if that made any
sense coming out of my mouth I would say
you were off for a week so it's gonna
take you some time for you to set it
anyway yeah you're right didn't mean
anything but yeah I understand that
whole aspect of it I do
I just really come down to the end of
the day wondering whether Tom wants to
do that like what is Oakland get out of
this yeah you're right I guess they get
out of the derrick karr conundrum maybe
to where this'll like nobody's gonna
question if they bring Tom Brady in the
town Hey
and the money I get thatis no I know and
the money and I wasn't just picking on
you Rudy don't like it too cuz it's
gonna piss Derek Carr off even if it
doesn't work out he's in the hope okay
if it doesn't work out buddy doesn't
come here maybe this will give this guy
the spine and the meanness that I want
to become the leader I want out of a
quarterback to where he kind of is
finally like hey fu Jon Gruden fu the
rest of the organization this is my you
know he starts to take over that way and
then maybe that's what Oakland doesn't
mind getting out of this proposition
either Jon Gruden quarterback [ __ ] Durr
looking for quarterbacks in the off C
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports